Prof: So today we're
going to finish up talking about
Nozick,
and that will give you time to
spend your spring break reading
Rawls,
which is, I know,
what you will all do.
But I want to come back to
something I mentioned briefly
about Nozick,
and just reiterate that he
thinks that in order to have a
convincing account of justice it
really has to have three
components.
One, what he calls justice in
acquisition.
Two, what he calls justice in
transfer.
And three, what he refers to as
the rectification of past
injustices.
You need accounts of all of
those things.
How people got to have what
they have, what should govern
transactions among them,
and then what should you do
about past injustices.
And actually in what we've done
already you've got the main
components of his account in
front of you,
or in your notes from last week
because his theory of justice in
acquisition is a theory that's
intended to respond to the left
critique of markets that I'm
going to talk about shortly.
His theory of justice in
transfer is the Pareto system,
and his theory of the
rectification of past injustices
is a discussion of compensation
that we had last time.
So let's think first about this
idea of justice in acquisition.
What he has in mind here is the
left critique of markets.
What he has in mind is the
garbage-in/garbage-out
phenomenon that the Pareto
principle is a purely procedural
principle that takes for granted
some status quo.
We worked through this with the
bag lady, and Trump and all of
that when we did the Pareto
system.
And he has actually an
ingenious answer to this
critique, and he uses as his way
into it the Wilt Chamberlain
example.
Anybody remember what Nozick
says about Wilt Chamberlain?
Who was Wilt Chamberlain?
Who was Wilt Chamberlain? Yeah?
Student:  Basketball
player.
Prof: He was the best
basketball player in the world
until Michael Jordan came along,
right?
Student:  Until Larry
Bird came along.
Prof: Until Larry Bird
came along.
Well, fortunately Nozick didn't
have to adjudicate that one.
And so Nozick said,
"Chamberlain is making a
contract with the owner of a
team just like professional
players do,
but this contract has a side
agreement to it.
Anyone remember what the side
agreement was?
What was the side agreement,
anybody?
Yeah, over there?
Student:  Wasn't it that
Wilt Chamberlain gets a quarter
of every dollar that the team
gets in ticket sales?
Prof: Exactly right.
So on nights when Wilt
Chamberlain is playing in a home
game,
the ticket price goes up by a
quarter,
and that quarter literally gets
dropped into a box and gets
given to Wilt.
And apart from that,
his agreement is like any other
contract.
So obviously his agreement with
the team owner is a typical
player's agreement,
and it's a Pareto superior
transaction,
and there's no question about
that.
But the reason Wilt Chamberlin
gets this quarter is because
he's a charismatic figure and
everybody wants to see him.
What is Nozick doing here?
What is the point of this?
What's he trying to show us?
Anyone want to--it's not
immediately obvious,
but it's quite brilliant.
So here's the point.
The point is,
over time Wilt is going to get
a lot of money from these
quarters because he's the best
basketball player in the world
and people want to see him.
So he's going to get richer,
and richer, and richer.
And so maybe,
let's say, after five seasons
of this, he has millions of
dollars in these quarters that
have accumulated.
These people have been putting
this quarter in the little box
that goes to Wilt,
millions.
Why is this a good example for
Nozick?
Yeah?
Give her--yeah,
over there, yeah.
Student:  Well,
perhaps he's showing that even
though this isn't an egalitarian
distribution of wealth,
it's mutually agreed-upon by
all parties involved so it's
okay.
Prof: So that Pareto
superior transaction every time
you put that quarter in that
slot,
you make a voluntary choice,
and he makes a voluntary choice
to come out and play and maybe
smile at you or something,
and both your utility goes up.
So it's in that sense just like
any other Pareto superior
transaction, so why the whole
rigmarole?
What else follows from this
example?
Think back.
Think back to what is his real
target here.
His real target is the left
critique of markets which says,
"If you start out with
unjust initial conditions,
if your system of justice in
acquisition isn't met,
then it doesn't matter whether
your transfers are
voluntary."
So what's he doing here?
What the point of this example?
Think.
Anyone want to have a go at it?
Yeah?
Student:  That what we'd
consider an unjust distribution
of goods or wealth may actually
result from what was originally
a just distribution.
Prof: Correct.
His bumper sticker is,
"Liberty upsets
patterns."
Liberty upsets patterns,
this is his point.
He's saying,
"Everybody gets so excited
about the unjust initial
conditions problem.
I'll tell you what.
I don't know what just initial
conditions are.
I have no idea, I Robert Nozick.
You pick.
You're an egalitarian,
fine, start with pure equality.
You believe in meritocracy,
fine, start with a meritocratic
distribution.
You pick.
I really don't care."
So let's, for the sake of
argument, just say you're an
egalitarian.
So you pick equality,
strict equality.
Everybody starts off with the
same amount.
Now we're going to allow
voluntary transactions.
You know what's going to happen?
You're going to get inequality
because some people are going to
put a quarter in the slot to see
Wilt Chamberlain.
So this stuff about the big
problem with markets,
the problem of starting points,
the problem of initial
conditions, it's just a red
herring.
It's a sideshow. It's bunk.
Because, in fact,
even if you pick--
so you're the egalitarian,
just for the sake of argument,
and you pick the starting point
that you are convinced is just,
and we allow markets to run,
it's going to be undone just by
the voluntary choices of
individuals.
"So, I,
Robert Nozick,
say to you, we'll have a little
syllogism.
If we have just initial
conditions and voluntary
transfers then the outcome must
be considered just."
That's Nozick's little
syllogism.
You have just initial
conditions and voluntary
transfers then the outcome must
be just.
It's just a shell game to get
all hung up on the initial
conditions, however,
because you can pick them and
we're still going to undo what
you like.
So you, the egalitarian pick
them.
People go to basketball games,
and what do you know?
Five years later you have a lot
of inequality,
and then the only way you can
fix it is coercion.
The only way you can fix it is
taking some of that away from
Chamberlain in the form of taxes
and giving it back to those
people in the form of some sort
of transfer payment,
and that violates his freedom,
uses him to benefit them,
nothing else.
So liberty upsets patterns.
When he talks about a pattern
conception of justice it's one
where you specify some
distribution whether it's strict
equality,
whether it's Bentham's
practical equality,
whether it's some other
distributive system,
whether you specify in advance
what the outcome is,
he's saying that's a pattern
conception,
and the problem with it is you
could only maintain it over time
with coercion.
Whereas, if you value freedom
of the individual,
liberty, remember Nozick is
another one of our Enlightenment
theorists so individual freedom,
individual rights is the
highest good,
then you have to accept
whatever voluntary transactions
generate starting from a system
which you have conceded is just.
So in a way he turns the table
on the left critic of markets by
calling their bluff,
and it's a brilliant argument.
Now you could say,
"Well, this is a
philosopher's example.
After all, we never start from
a system that is universally
accepted to be just."
But I think he would make two
points in response to that.
One is, "I'm showing you
that even if you did you would
still have this problem that
over time it would get undone by
the voluntary transactions of
individuals."
And secondly,
Nozick wrote this in 1974,
but I think if he had
lived--well, he did live long
enough.
He died about three years ago,
but if he had been writing this
book after the early 1990s,
he'd have had some very good
real world examples of what he
was talking about following the
collapse of the Soviet Union,
because in a lot of East
European countries,
such as Czechoslovakia and East
Germany they had these huge
state enterprises that they had
decided to privatize.
And what did they do?
Well, they basically privatized
them on an egalitarian basis.
That seemed fair.
So there would be these giant
factories that had been
previously state owned and
everybody would get their little
chit.
Everybody would get their share
of that factory.
It was very widespread in
Czechoslovakia and Poland in
particular, but also in some of
the other ex-communist
countries.
And what happened?
Well, some people didn't know
what they were,
probably rolled cigarettes with
them,
some people put them under the
bed,
some people threw them away,
some people put them in
shoeboxes,
some people started buying them
up,
started going around and buying
up pieces of this factory that
had been given out as a result
of the privatization.
And what do you know?
Five years later,
ten years later,
some of the people who had
figured out this might be a good
thing to do were millionaires,
and other people basically
didn't have anything.
So it's not a completely
fanciful example,
right?
And Nozick would say,
"There you go.
What was decided as a fair
distribution of the state assets
at the moment of privatization
was accomplished,
but then markets were allowed
to run,
and some people took risks,
and some people were creative.
Maybe some people spent all of
their savings buying these
things up so they internalized
some risk,
they might have turned out not
to have any value,
and they got the benefit.
And so there you go,
five years later you have
inequality.
Liberty upsets patterns.
Now are we going to go and take
the millions from the people who
bought up those chits and give
it back to the people who rolled
them and smoked as cigarettes,
or gave them away,
or lost them,
in order to recreate the
pattern?
Nozick says no, right?
And this is what he means by
comparing what he calls
historical principles or
procedural principles,
on the one hand,
with pattern principles or
end-state principles on the
other hand.
An end-state principle
specifies some result,
some end-state,
some condition,
some teleological outcome,
to use the jargon from last
time, whereas a historical or a
procedural principle specifies
no pattern at all and says
whatever is generated by market
transactions is just.
And this long two
hundred-year-old critique of
them based on the status quo,
we now see from the Wilt
Chamberlain example,
is just smoke.
What about that?
It's a powerful argument.
Anyone not like it?
You all like it?
What's wrong with it?
What makes you uncomfortable?
Can you give her the microphone?
Can you right next--can you
just give her--yeah,
okay, thanks.
Student: I'd say that the thing
that's being distributed doesn't
necessarily have to be money.
If you change the thing being
distributed to,
I don't know,
education, for example,
that having equality there
might be something that would
affect outcomes more than
starting from a concrete
equality.
Professor Ian Shapiro:
And why should we care about
that?
Student: Well,
I guess it's kind of a way of
changing the process as opposed
to...
Professor Ian Shapiro:
Okay, so that's fair enough,
so that's one thing somebody
might like about it.
Anything else anyone doesn't
like about it?
Student: Well,
Wilt Chamberlain is kind of
like a self-made...
Professor Ian Shapiro:
You've got to talk a bit
louder.
Student: Wilt Chamberlain is
kind of like a self-made person.
He gets there because of his
basketball talents,
but it kind of ignores the
problem of people who are born
into incredible wealth or born
into incredible opportunity.
Professor Ian Shapiro:
How does it ignore it?
Student: Well,
I feel like in the situation
with Wilt Chamberlain he
realizes that he deserves what
he gets and you shouldn't take
it away from him,
but I don't know if you can
argue that having being born
into a family that has a lot of
money,
or being born somewhere where
you can barely put food on the
table is necessarily someone's
more deserving of having one or
the other.
Professor Ian Shapiro:
Okay, so, but that's what he
thinks he's answering,
right?
Because he's saying,
"Okay,
so you're worried that some
people are born with a lot of
resources and some are born with
nothing."
He's saying,
"Fix it however you want.
So we'll start off by
redistributing and we'll start
off with pure equality.
If you allow markets to run,
it's still going to become
unequal over time,"
right?
That's his point.
So what don't you like about
that?
Student: Well,
I feel like there's a problem
in the way that--
maybe it's that he believes
that the markets are truly free
in some way and that there are
really free transactions,
but I feel like there's not
necessarily going to be,
ever.
Prof: But isn't that why
he uses the Wilt Chamberlin and
it's only a quarter?
It's only a quarter for crying
out loud, and you didn't have to
give it.
It's a trivial amount,
but there it is five years
later, he's the millionaire and
you're still working in a
factory.
You're not comfortable with it?
Student:  No.
Prof: But you're not
sure why.
Anybody else want to say what?
It's a very clever example.
It's an example of where the
philosopher's example really
cuts to something important.
Yeah, what's wrong with it?
Student:  Well,
it seems like Wilt Chamberlain
is an exception.
Prof: Wilt Chamberlain's
an exception,
why?
Student:  Because the
poor will tend to stay poor and
the rich will tend to stay rich,
and just because there's
occasional disruption of the
pattern doesn't mean the pattern
will be fluctuating all over the
place.
Prof: Okay,
so he's unusual,
but what about the--
okay, lets grant your point,
but what about the example I
just gave of Poland after 1989?
Everybody starts out equal and
it's just that some people see
an opportunity here and they get
rich, and other people don't and
they lose out.
Student:  Well,
Nozick is relegating the
principles to the very
beginning.
He's saying you can only apply
your principles at the beginning
and he doesn't let you do that
as a continuous thing.
Prof: Well,
I don't think he'd back down
that quickly.
He'd say, "Look,
the point of this example is
I'm letting you define the
beginning."
So after 1989,
the Polish government defines
the new beginning.
Everybody gets an equal share
of state assets.
We're creating private property
for the first time.
Everybody's getting an equal
share, but five years later we
have inequality.
Yes ma'am?
Student:  To use,
in particular,
the example with the shares of
factories in the Soviet Union,
I think that Nozick is perhaps
making the false assumption that
everyone is going to have equal
ability to make use of that fair
distribution at the beginning,
when in fact people who are
poor are not going to be able to
buy up the other shares of the
factories,
and it's going to exacerbate
inequality that was already
there.
Prof: Well,
your point is well-taken,
but notice I said
Czechoslovakia and Poland
because in Soviet Union what
tended to happen was bureaucrats
from the old system used their
special position in the
bureaucracy and their intimate
knowledge of what was going on
to enrich themselves and grab a
lot of these assets.
So I didn't want to go with
that example,
but in the East European
countries there was a lot less
of that,
and it was more of a sort of
genuine new beginning.
But you still,
you look at a country like
Poland and it rapidly became
massively unequal.
Student: Well,
that makes sense,
but I would assume that those
small inequalities that existed
in Poland at the beginning of
that redistribution ended up
creating those massive
inequalities.
Professor Ian Shapiro:
That's right.
It's just like one quarter at a
time.
Student: Right.
Professor Ian Shapiro:
Okay, but that's Nozick's
point.
You don't need some massive
injustice to be done at the
beginning in order to get huge
inequalities over time.
Let's modify the Wilt
Chamberlain example a little
bit.
Well, before I do that,
how many people think that the
outcome in the Wilt Chamberlain
is just fine,
so he gets rich,
but people want him to get
rich?
So okay, how many think it's
not fine?
Okay, a few,
so now let's play with it a
little bit and see if your
opinion changes.
Let's just imagine it's a
single company town,
okay?
It's a single company town.
All these people who go to
these games basically work in
the only factory in town.
And let's just imagine that
after five or eight years of
this when he's getting close to
retirement,
and he's not playing such good
basketball anymore anyway,
Wilt says to himself,
"You know what I'm going
to do?
I'm going to buy the only
factory in town,"
and he buys the factory in
which they all work.
And so he now owns the factory,
Pareto superior transaction,
voluntary transaction.
He uses these millions he's
accumulated from all of their
quarters to buy the factory.
But times are tough.
There's globalization coming
along.
The factory's losing money,
and his manager says to him,
"You've got to massively
cut your wages here."
And so he gets into a
confrontation with the workers,
and they won't back down,
and his company he thinks is
not making as much money as it
should,
and so he says, "Well,
unless you take a seventy
percent pay cut,
I'm moving this company to
Mexico."
So they are,
in effect, forced to take a
seventy percent pay cut as a
result of this transaction.
Now what about that?
What would Nozick say?
What would Nozick say about
that?
Nozick would be fine with it,
wouldn't he?
Yeah, that's the way the cookie
crumbles, right?
"Losses must lie where
they fall"
is a famous line from an
American judge called Learned
Hand.
That's what happened.
They chose to give him all of
this money.
Maybe they didn't anticipate
what he was going to do with it,
but that was then and this is
now, and he's entitled to do
whatever he wants with his
money.
How many people think that
changes this thing?
If we doctor Nozick's example
in this way does anybody think
it changes anything,
somebody who previously thought
it was okay but now is less
sure?
There's nobody?
Yeah? Why?
Let's get the mic there yeah,
over here, yeah?
Yeah.
Student: I don't have a real
explanation.
I just think it's morally wrong
because it's kind of coercing
the people to go by his money
and everything,
while before he was just kind
of earning money for his own
happiness,
and his own utility, I guess.
In this case he's using his
money and it seems to have bad
moral implications,
so that's why I'm slightly more
uneasy with this outcome.
Professor Ian Shapiro:
So it's what he's doing with
it.
He's taking advantage of the
situation in some way?
Student: I guess so, yeah.
Professor Ian Shapiro:
Well, anyone want to disagree
with that?
Yeah?
Student: Well,
I think it changes the
situation in a different way in
that now we're have coercion of
a group of people to keep the
pattern of Wilt Chamberlain
being in charge intact.
So even though it does seem at
first glance like a mutually
beneficial arrangement it seems
as though people are being
coerced into doing something in
order to maintain a...
Professor Ian Shapiro:
But where's the coercion?
Student: Well,
they're being coerced into
taking this pay cut even though
it seems as though a really bad
move for them,
so...
I mean, they have no choices,
so I guess they've been back
into this corner,
but...
Prof: Well,
they have the choice of not
being employed by Wilt,
right?
Student:  I guess so.
I don't know.
Prof: We have this essay
question which some of you are
probably working on.
Joan Robinson's line,
"The one thing worse than
being exploited is not being
exploited,"
but he's saying,
"I'm choosing to close
down my factory and move it to
Mexico.
I'm not coercing you.
I just don't want to run a
factory at a loss."
Most people wouldn't allow the
market to run indefinitely.
So for instance,
we have laws if you have a
hurricane and there's no water
in a part of the country that's
been hit by the hurricane,
and the local hardware store
with bottled water suddenly
ramps up the price a thousand
percent.
We call it price gouging.
It's an evil thing.
But he would say,
"Look, the demand for
water just went way up.
I have water.
Why should it be price
gouging?"
So that's the point of the
outsourcing example,
right?
The point is,
at some point most people are
going to say,
"No, we can't just allow
the market.
We have to pay attention to the
context in which people are
buying water right after a
hurricane.
Through no fault of their own,
the price of water has
skyrocketed,
and so we're going to have laws
to punish people who engage in
price gouging."
Who thinks that we should have
laws against price gouging?
Yeah?
Now, if we should have laws
against price gouging shouldn't
we have laws against the sort of
thing that Wilt Chamberlain is,
in my modification of Nozick's
example,
is proposing to do?
Anyone think we should have
laws against price gouging,
but we shouldn't have laws
limiting what--no?
Is that right?
What he's threatening to do is
like price gouging,
or anybody think it's not like
price gouging?
So what's the difference? Yeah?
Student:  No,
I was thinking it's like Mill's
harm principle a little bit,
so maybe you could actually
find for price gouging and for
Wilt Chamberlain a reason to
allow a government to say that
you're not allowed to do it even
though it seems perfectly fine
as a market transaction.
Prof: But what is the
difference exactly?
Student:  I'm saying
they're similar because they
both involve harming people.
Prof: They both involve
harming people,
but the price gouging is worse
somehow than what Wilt is
proposing to do?
Student:  I'm not saying
that it's necessarily worse.
It could be,
but I don't have a definite
reason to say so.
Prof: So I think
Nozick's point is going to be,
"Well, anytime you're
going to step in,
anytime the government is going
to step in and say this crosses
some line where even though it's
voluntary transactions,
they're not voluntary in any
meaningful sense because people
are such extremists."
The price-gouging situation is
an example, but you're still
going to have to say,
"Well, how do we know
where to draw that line?
When is it going to be the case
that the position we're putting
people in and saying
"choose"
is so bad that the government
steps in?
Is it when they're about to
die, or is it not quite that
far?
Where are we going to decide?
What is the point at which we
step in and start making
interpersonal judgments of
utility?"
That's what we're really
saying, right?
We're saying,
"At some point we're going
to step in,
the state's going to step in,
but we don't have a very good
account of at what point."
Because if you say,
"At no point is the state
going to step in,"
then you're really back to
saying in the example we talked
about way back with the
Edgeworth Box that the bag lady
should die because she has
nothing that Trump wants,
and so that's the Pareto
efficient result.
But if you want to say,
"Well,
at some point before that
point, the state should step
in," you need some account
of what it is.
And given that things happen
and circumstances change,
just saying if the initial
conditions were just and the
transactions were voluntary the
outcome must be just,
isn't going to be satisfying in
every instance because the
status quo changes.
There can be drift,
if you like,
utility drift,
in the status quo.
And different people will think
the state should get involved at
different points,
but there are very people,
I think,
who are going to go all the way
and say,
"Well, the bag lady should
just die,"
or "All these people
should lose their jobs."
Maybe that'll be a more
difficult case for some of you
than for others,
but it doesn't seem very
credible to say you're not going
to have any point at which we're
going to say the state should
step in.
But now Nozick would want to
say, "Well,
even if I conceded that,
we really want to keep it to a
minimum because the problem is
we don't agree.
The problem about having any
pattern or end-state conception
of what's allowable in society
is we don't agree.
We have deep pluralism of
values in this society.
What some people think is right
other people don't think is
right,
and why should the people who
are in the majority get to
impose their view on everybody
else,
or indeed, why should people
who are in a minority get to
impose their view on anybody
else?
Why should anybody get to
impose their view on anybody
else?"
That's his claim,
and we saw in the last lecture
that he made a distinction
between redistribution and
compensation,
remember?
He said that we would only get
the minimal state as a result of
forcible inclusion of
independents if they could,
in principle,
be compensated making it
legitimate.
We wouldn't get anything more
because people don't agree.
So some people would say it's
terrible for people to lose
their jobs.
Others would say,
"Oh well,
they should have thought about
that when they were putting all
those quarters in the box,
that they're giving him
power."
So if you cast your mind back
to last week's lecture on
Wednesday,
we ended up saying, "Well,
Nozick's argument isn't as
powerful as it looks because we
could do more in the name of
compensation than he wants to
do," right?
We could allow the creation of
unemployment insurance.
Remember there's the fear of
being unemployed in all of that.
So he might agree about that
but say, "It's still better
to think in a compensatory
idiom."
For one thing,
yes, you might get unemployment
insurance that way,
but think of all the things the
welfare state does.
It gives protection to the
disabled, it gives civil rights
guarantees.
These are all sorts of things
that wouldn't come about because
not enough people would want
them.
The disabled are a minority.
The African Americans before
the Civil Rights Act were a
minority,
so they wouldn't be able to
force everybody to accept what
they wanted so it wouldn't get
done as a result of the kind of
mechanism that creates the
minimal state.
There'd be a lot of things
government currently does that
wouldn't happen.
And it's better to have
compensation rather than
redistribution,
because compensation doesn't
require us to agree about a
pattern.
It doesn't require us to agree
on what kind of outcome is
actually just.
The whole idea of compensation
is making somebody whole.
If one of you walks up to the
street and punches me in the
face,
and I go to court and sue you,
the question is what damage did
that angry student do to Ian
Shapiro,
and how much should Shapiro be
compensated to put him on at
least as high an indifference
curve as he was before that,
right? That's the only question.
We don't have to ask the
question, should he have been
where he was before?
Is the distribution of wealth
in society that existed before
Shapiro was punched by the angry
student, was that just?
We don't have to ask that
question.
If we're going to do
compensation we just say,
"How do we make Shapiro
whole?
How does the person who harmed
him make him whole?
How much money does he have to
give him to make him
whole?"
That's the only question we
have to answer.
And Nozick wants to say that
it's a much easier thing to deal
with precisely because in a
society where there's deep
pluralism of values,
where we don't agree on what's
just,
it's a much more limited
inquiry into how do we
compensate some particular
individual to undo the
particular harm that was done to
them and make them whole.
We don't have to agree on what
the just distribution of wealth
and income in this society is in
order to answer that question,
right?
Is that a good argument that
compensation is much less
demanding metaphysically than
redistribution,
because compensation doesn't
require us to agree on what is
just.
It just requires us to figure
out how much is owed to Shapiro
to make him whole after this
harm has been done to him.
Yeah? Is it a good argument?
Student:  Just because
it's easy doesn't mean it's the
right argument.
Prof: Just because it's
easy doesn't mean it's the right
argument, but is it easy?
Student:  Well,
you said it was,
just metaphysically.
Prof: It's easy in one
sense.
I mean it might be hard because
I'm going to say,
"Pain and suffering,
and I was humiliated,
and I've got to get extra money
for that,
and my girlfriend won't look at
me because I've got a black eye,
I should get extra money for
that."
We'll argue about this in
court, so it might be hard in
that sense,
but it's easier in the sense
that we don't need to agree on
what my salary should be versus
a banker's salary,
versus--you know,
we don't have to answer
questions like that.
We just want to know the
number--we have to arrive at the
number to undo the harm,
to make me whole.
Is that a bad argument?
Yeah?
Student:  Well,
it completely forgets the
Enlightenment idea that there
might be a right answer to
anything,
and just by saying that you're
just dealing in compensation and
not actually redistribution and
figuring out...
Prof: I mean,
yeah, that's a good point,
but I think Nozick would say,
"I'm not saying there
isn't a right answer.
I'm saying we don't agree on
what the right answer is,
but I, Nozick,
am saying one right answer's
not to coerce people,
so given that we have different
values the answer is liberty.
Let everybody have their own
value and not impose one
person's value on others."
So I don't think he'd back down
that quickly.
Is there any other reason
anyone might think this is--I
think you're in the right
direction, but you haven't quite
nailed it.
Yeah?
Student:  So,
I mean, in terms of money,
maybe it's easier to think
about compensation,
but when you're compensating
people with goods or services
you're really having to take
those from somewhere else.
They don't just appear out of
nowhere.
So, on some level you're
already redistributing things
when you're compensating.
So it is really just another
form of redistribution,
but in another word.
Prof: I think that's a
good argument,
but I think there's another one
that I just want to leave you
with,
and this partly reflects when
Nozick was writing.
He wrote this in 1974,
and in 1974,
there was a lot more political
stability in the world in some
ways than there came to be
subsequently.
Of course it was unstable in
the sense that we were in the
middle of the Cold War,
but the Cold War provided a lot
of stability within countries
that would subsequently become
very unstable after the end of
the Cold War.
And so this idea that,
well, fixing one injustice is
something we can get our minds
around,
particularly if it means making
people as well-off as they were
before,
whereas deciding what's just
for the society as a whole
isn't.
It's a much bigger problem,
and it is potentially much more
politically explosive,
because we're going to be,
as Nozick says,
"Liberty upsets
patterns."
We're going to be taking wealth
from some people and giving it
to other people,
and the people we're taking it
from are not going to like it.
Whereas this compensatory idiom
is backward-looking,
it's focused and it's specific.
But I think what he didn't take
account of is that the
backward-looking idiom runs into
the problem of where do we stop.
Where do we stop?
After 1991, there were people
in Russia who said,
"All that property should
be given back to the czar's
children."
After the transition in South
Africa King Goodwill Zwelithini,
the Zulu King,
he said, "Well,
all that land that was seized
first by the British from my
ancestors,
and then under apartheid was
seized again for the forced
removals and all that,
it should be given to me.
I'm the descendant."
And you only have to think
about the Middle East to see
that this idea that a
backward-looking compensatory
idiom is less politically
explosive than a redistributive
idiom as a political matter
isn't true,
because it all depends how far
you go back.
The Palestinians say we go back
to 1967,
or then there's the debate
about going back to 1948,
and there are many people who
are there that say,
"We should go back to the
Old Testament as to where we
should undo all the injustices
that are piled up upon one
another over time."
So this idea that the
compensatory idiom is less
demanding than the
redistributive idiom I think is
politically naive and ultimately
philosophically not tenable
because you're going to have to
make a decision about how far
back to go before you decide
that you have the benchmark for
compensation.
You only have to look at the
vexed history of affirmative
action which was,
you know, read Randall
Robinson's book,
The Debt,
the vexed history of
affirmative action,
to see how difficult a
backward-looking compensatory
idiom turns out to be in
practice.
Enjoy the midterm and we'll see
you three weeks from today.